this episode of shots of awe is brought
to you by the Toyota Prius let's lead
the way
[Music]
kevin kelly used to say humans are the
sex organs of technology what he meant
by that was that technology was a living
organism that was using us to extend its
reproductive capacities similar to the
way Pollan right those pollen flowers
use bees in order to spread their seeds
the history of technology highlights
what's known as bootstrapping
essentially we use one technology to
build the next technology and then we
use the next technology to build the
next technology and so on and so forth
until what we have is a telescoping
nature of evolutionary change in which
the nature of change itself changes and
so what we have really to define the
human story is what's known as
transforming and transcending we use
these technological scaffoldings to
build new capabilities bring them into
our cognitive arsenal and then create
new possibility spaces for ourselves
probably the adjacent possible we remix
what is we create virtual models we
actualize those new virtual models into
existence essentially our mastery of
technology has given us new construction
kits for our reality and I love this
idea Eric Davis said it best the human
design process will achieve a kind of
infinite velocity where everything
becomes linked with everything else and
matter becomes mind
[Music]
you